Nous sommes en train de considérer ce concept très important dans l'être au Galate,
le concept du fruit de l'esprit,
qui sert dans l'intentionnalité de l'apôtre Paul
comme exhortation, comme appel à l'action
et rappel de l'identité de ses croyants qui étaient en train d'osciller dans la foi.
Une église qui vivait en crise, qui traversait des disputes internes,
qui manquait d'amour.
Mais les manques d'amour que cette église était en train de vivre à ces moments
ne représentaient pas la vérité à propos de ses croyants.
Car les manifestations évidentes d'amour pour Dieu
et pour leur communauté, pour les prochains et même pour les perdus
étaient très évidentes déjà
et étaient prédominants dans leur parcours de foi.
Donc ici, Paul ramène cet appel
afin qu'il soit redressé.
Donc nous ne sommes pas devant, quelque part,
un nouveau début dans la foi.
Ils n'ont pas perdu leur salut.
Leur salut n'a pas été mis en question.
C'est un appel ou un rappel
de leur vraie identité en tant qu'enfant des dieux
et un appel à vivre à la hauteur de leur nouvelle nature
et faire valoir les privilèges d'être habitation
du Saint-Esprit des dieux
qui produit en nous la vie des dieux.
Donc les fruits de l'Esprit ici
est cette base
sur laquelle Paul
appelle les croyants
dans cette Église
à évaluer l'authenticité de leur salut,
à chérir la puissance du Saint-Esprit
et de leur nouvelle nature
qui est à leur disposition
pour manifester une vie
qui est la meilleure vie qu'ils pourraient désirer
et en même temps celle qui plaît le plus le Seigneur.
Donc les fruits de l'Esprit
deviennent pour nous tous, pour cette Église,
une évidence nécessaire
et suffisante pour identifier un enfant des dieux.
Si le Saint-Esprit n'est pas là,
personne ne peut avoir les types d'amour,
des joies, des paix, des patience, des bontés
dont ce texte nous parle.
Et donc ici nous ne sommes pas devant des conditions
pour que les personnes puissent devenir enfants des dieux,
nous sommes devant des évidences
que tous les chrétiens
ont la capacité par l'Esprit
de manifester et de produire.
Et donc, si nous voulons être sûrs de notre salut,
nous devons identifier la manifestation de ces fruits.
Et si nous voulons nous épanouir en tant que chrétiens,
nous devons cultiver de plus en plus
et maximiser la manifestation du fruit de l'Esprit dans notre vie.
Et donc afin d'identifier
et afin de cultiver et maximiser
la manifestation du fruit de l'Esprit,
les croyants, ils doivent
comprendre quelle est la nature
et les fonctionnements du fruit de l'Esprit
et la considération de plusieurs vérités à cet égard.
Nous l'avons conclu le dimanche dernier.
Et il faut aussi considérer la nature spécifique
de chacune de ces facettes.
Donc, qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là ?
La première étape qu'on a couvert,
c'était de considérer la nature de l'arbre
et apprendre comment nous pouvons cultiver.
De quelle nature est ces fruits ?
De nous rappeler que ces fruits
ne peuvent pas être produits par nos propres efforts.
Nous sommes considérés plutôt comme des branches
dans une totale dépendance
qui est les racines,
qui est la nature de l'arbre,
qui est la sève,
coulent à travers nous pour produire son fruit.
Et nous, des branches greffées à Christ par l'Esprit,
avons les privilèges de manifester les fruits du Christ,
la vie du Christ.
Et donc, la nature et le fonctionnement de ces fruits
nous ont rappelé que c'est un fruit organiquement connecté
à l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit en nous.
Sans l'Esprit du Christ,
Christ ne peut pas être manifesté chez nous.
Nous avons compris que si c'est l'Esprit
qui peut produire et quel Esprit qui peut produire,
ce sont des attributs, des vertus,
essentiellement spirituelles,
et pour plus qu'on puisse identifier
dans une certaine faible manifestation
et toujours corrompue dans tous les êtres humains,
sans le Saint-Esprit,
une petite portion corrompue des patiences,
d'amour, etc.,
par réalité, c'est que l'Esprit
ou les vertus dont l'Esprit est à l'origine
sont profondément spirituelles,
complètement et essentiellement
différentes de ce qu'on comprend,
de ce qu'on connaît de l'amour
en termes corrompus.
On a considéré aussi que
les fruits de l'Esprit sont indivisibles,
donc c'est dans les sanguliers,
le fruit de l'Esprit,
et donc toutes ces facettes
doivent toujours se présenter
de manière symétrique,
équilibrée,
dans la vie de tous les chrétiens.
Là où le Saint-Esprit habite,
l'évidence,
c'est qu'il vivra une vie
caractérisée par la présence
de toutes ces facettes.
Et voilà pourquoi
c'est un fruit indivisible
car il représente une personne,
les caractères du Christ,
et donc cette intégrité.
Nous avons considéré
que les fruits de l'Esprit
sont permanents
car l'Esprit Saint
nous a été donné
comme les gages
de notre héritage,
les prémices
de cette vie future,
glorieuse
qu'on aura pour toujours.
Et donc,
le Saint-Esprit,
une fois conféré
à un vrai croyant,
il ne sortira jamais
et son ministère principal
c'est de révéler Christ
à nous
et de former Christ
en nous.
Et donc,
c'est le Saint-Esprit
qui assure
que nous,
en tant qu'ébranche
greffée à Christ,
manifesterons inévitablement
la vie de Christ
même si parfois
nous sommes oscillants
dans notre foi.
Car,
et ça c'est le dernier
ou la dernière caractéristique
qu'on a considérée
par rapport à la nature
et le fonctionnement
de cet arbre
ou du fruit de l'Esprit,
c'est que nous coopérons
pour être greffés à Christ
ça ne dépend pas de nous.
C'est le Saint-Esprit
qui doit travailler
exclusivement pour les faire.
Mais une fois greffés à Christ,
nous avons reçu
une nature
nouvelle,
radicale.
Et notre volonté prédominante
marche dans la direction
de la volonté de l'Esprit
et nous sommes donc responsables
et rédévables
pour coopérer
avec l'Esprit,
cultiver et accueillir
ses influences
afin de manifester
chaque fois plus ses fruits.
Donc nous devons cultiver
par notre relation
avec les Saint-Esprits
à travers les moyens
des grâces,
la parole,
l'Église,
la prière.
Nous devons intentionnellement
cultiver les fruits
de l'Esprit.
Donc en ayant considéré
ces choses,
il faut toujours
les rappeler,
nous passons
de la considération
du cadre général,
de la compréhension générale
à la compréhension spécifique.
Car nous sommes appelés
à cultiver
les fruits de l'Esprit
ayant reçu
au verset 23
une définition
plus claire
de ce qui est
les fruits de l'Esprit.
Et là,
on a l'amour,
la joie,
la paix.
Donc il nous faut
cultiver
intentionnellement
chacune de ces facettes.
Et c'est ça
que nous passerons
à faire désormais.
Nous allons considérer
les fruits en soi
que nous devons chercher
à cultiver
et maximiser.
Et nous allons commencer
aujourd'hui,
bien sûr,
par cette première mention,
cette première vertu
mentionnée,
l'amour.
Et nous allons donc
avoir pour objectif
principal aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'afin d'identifier
et maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'Esprit,
les croyants doivent
identifier,
connaître
et cultiver
intentionnellement
l'amour.
C'est un amour
clairement d'ordre biblique,
d'ordre spirituel,
impossible
sans l'Esprit.
Et nous avons donc
les privilèges
et la responsabilité
de connaître
cet amour
et de le cultiver.
Nous allons
dans les prochains dimanches
cherchés
à mieux
définir
bibliquement
cette compréhension
de cet amour
spirituel.
Mais pour ne pas
tomber dans les risques
qui ont été évoqués
dans les offrandes
et dans la prière
pastorale,
nous voulons
d'abord
traverser
une considération
qui cherche
plutôt
cette connaissance
expérimentale
de l'amour
des dieux
révélée en Christ
par l'Esprit.
et donc
ça fait partie
de cultiver
cet amour
une compréhension
qui cherche
la précision
biblique
mais nous savons
que l'amour
même dans les descriptions
bibliques
n'a pas
qui est une dimension
tout simplement
comportementale
ou théorique
ou mécanique.
Et donc
l'objectif
aujourd'hui
c'est surtout
de considérer
l'ordre
d'importance
de la conception
biblique
d'amour
surtout
par la considération
de sa perspective
expérimentale
car même si
les chrétiens
peuvent ne pas
avoir
un niveau
théologique
qui connaît
l'étymologie
des termes bibliques
pour décrire
l'amour
tous les vrais
chrétiens
sont nés
de l'amour
des dieux
à cause
de l'amour
des dieux
pour aimer
Dieu
être imprégnés
de l'amour
des dieux
et communiquer
l'amour des dieux
donc être enracinés
dans l'amour des dieux
est quelque chose
de profondément
expérimental
et tous
doivent connaître
donc aujourd'hui
on va considérer
cette grande vérité
les croyants
doivent
identifier
dans sa vie
et cultiver
davantage
surtout
l'amour
de l'esprit
car
l'amour
de l'esprit
est la vertu
capitale
et toute
intégratrice
du fruit
de l'esprit
l'amour
il vient
en premier
dans la liste
mais le fruit
de l'esprit
c'est l'amour
plusieurs commentaristes
vont parler
que toutes ces facettes
doivent toujours
être présentes
ensemble
mais un grand nombre
des commentaristes
reconnaît aussi
qui est non seulement
par ces passages
mais par plusieurs
autres passages
des écritures
l'amour
est évidemment
la vertu
la plus importante
elle est la vertu
d'abord
car elle apparaît
imprimée
dans la liste
ni toutes les listes
bibliques
sont
exhaustives
dans
ces ordres
c'est-à-dire
dans l'ordre
qui apparaît
les vertus
parfois
on va voir
que l'ordre
des vertus
qui sont répétés
peut osciller
en dépendant
du contexte
certains
certaines facettes
peuvent ne pas
être mentionnées
donc nous ne cherchons
pas à
enrigir trop
cette liste
qu'il y a là
mais souvent
les premières
vertus
dans les listes
ou dans l'ordre
des présentations
des choses
a beaucoup
d'intentionnalité
de la part des dieux
pour nous les révéler
quand on pense
par exemple
à cet ordre
extraordinaire
qu'on va retrouver
dans la manière
dont Christ
dans les béatitudes
va présenter
ce qui est
les caractères
chrétiens
il y a une symétrie
incroyable
il y a une liaison
logique
d'une vertu
à l'autre
et il y a toujours
quelque chose
de prioritaire
soit par rapport
à l'ordre
dont les choses
se passent
soit par rapport
à l'ordre
d'importance
et nous devons
être sensibles
et considérer
la Bible
pour considérer
ces choses
donc ici
l'amour
nous est présenté
comme
les premiers
aspects
du fruit
de l'esprit
car c'est
quelque chose
qui nous ressentons
les premiers
lorsqu'on traverse
l'expérience
des conversions
dans notre expérience
quand quelqu'un
se convertit
il est convaincu
de cet amour
de Dieu
prédisposé
à nous pardonner
manifesté
à la croix
du Christ
et l'expérience
des conversions
c'est de ressentir
l'amour
de Dieu
et plus intéressant
c'est de considérer
qui est toujours
dans la Bible
si nous croyons
comme nous les croyons
que la Bible
est inspirée
plénèrement
et verbalement
c'est à dire
dans son ensemble
et dans chaque particule
nous devons comprendre
qu'il y a
de l'intentionnalité
dans les saints esprits
d'écrire la Bible
telle qu'elle est
dans l'ordre
qu'elle a écrit
donc déjà
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans la Bible
l'importance
de l'amour
dans plusieurs
listes différentes
qui vont mentionner
l'amour
donc par exemple
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est ce qu'on est
en train de considérer
mais il y a
une reconnaissance
de la part
des théologiens
donc notamment
une formulation
ou une terminologie
qui est amenée
par Thomas d'Aquand
de parler
de la triade
théologale
c'est que
pour les réformés
on a considéré
parfois
les triades royales
les trois vertus
les plus importantes
sans lesquelles
il n'y a pas
la vraie foi
donc si nous allons
par exemple
en 1ère Corinthiens 13
verset 13
donc ces trois choses
demeurent
la foi
l'espérance
l'amour
mais la plus grande
ces choses
c'est l'amour
foi
espérance
et amour
1ère Thessaloniciens
1.3
nous nous souvenons
sans cesse
de votre oeuvre
des fois
foi
du travail
de votre amour
et de la fermeté
de votre espérance
foi
espérance
amour
en nouveau
1ère Thessaloniciens
5.8
mais nous qui sommes
du jour
soyons sobres
ayant revêtu
la curette
de la foi
et de l'amour
ayant pour casque
l'espérance
du salut
Colossians 1.4
et 5
ayant été informés
de votre foi
en Jésus-Christ
et de votre amour
pour tous les sangs
à cause de l'espérance
qui vous est réservée
dans les cieux
et qui vous avez entendus
par la parole
de la vérité
foi
espérance
et amour
elles sont appelées
les vertus royales
ce qui est important
pour nous à remarquer
c'est que ces
trois vertus
caractérisent plutôt
les débuts
de notre foi
et la manière
dont cette foi
sera développée
quelque part
quand on pense
au fruit de l'esprit
les résultats
de cette relation
avec Dieu
dans nos vies
et il progressera
sur la base
de ces trois vertus
et quelque part
nous sommes ici
devant
une notion
qui s'oriente
vers l'ordre
de notre salut
donc l'évangile
nous est présenté
et nous déposons
notre foi
en Christ
c'est lui
qui nous est présenté
comme celui
qui vit la vie parfaite
à notre place
qui est mort à la croix
pour payer
pour nos péchés
et nous plaçons
notre foi
en lui
par contre
c'est impossible
que cette foi
n'ait pas
pour nature
pour essence
ne soit pas exercée
dans une expérience
dont la nature
même de cette foi
est l'amour
et cet amour
deviendra
progressivement
croissant
les plus
les chrétiens
comprend
la manière
dont Christ
l'a sauvé
les plus
les chrétiens
comprend
où le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
est en train
de nous amener
les plus
on s'approfondit
dans la connaissance
de l'évangile
les plus grandissant
sera l'amour
expérimental
du chrétien
et cet cadre
d'assurance
cette espérance
qui ne confond pas
c'est car
par les Saint-Esprits
on a été scellé
et par l'expérience
avec cet amour
fidèle de Dieu
qui ne désiste
jamais de nous
nous avons
l'assurance
que l'espérance
chrétienne
n'est pas
envie d'espoir
il n'est pas
en train
de penser
optimiste
de manière optimiste
ou
comment
un supporteur
parfois
pense pouvoir
faire quelque chose
par la manière
dont il supporte
c'est une espérance
vivante
vivifiante
et certaine
et donc
toutes les oscillations
de la vie chrétienne
n'ont pas la capacité
d'empêcher
la croissance
de cet amour
et la manifestation
et c'est clair donc
que la substance
de la croissance
dans la sanctification
ou dans la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit
elle sera proportionnelle
à la manière
dont
ma foi
a engendré
une relation
d'intimité
avec l'amour
de Dieu
la compréhension
de ma foi
et de l'amour
de Dieu
me fait grandir
dans l'expérience
de cet amour
et ma certitude
que toutes les promesses
de Dieu
vont s'accomplir
dans ma vie
vont me donner
les cadres
d'assurance
nécessaires
pour continuer
à progresser
à manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
malgré les difficultés
que je puisse traverser
et donc
ces trois vertus
elles sont
dans notre ordre
quelque part
quand on pense
aux fruits de l'esprit
car elles sont
elles ont un point de départ
qui a déclenché
notre foi
et elles soutiennent
car ce sont des choses
qu'on reçoit
directement de Dieu
et qui parlent
surtout de notre relation
directe avec Dieu
et c'est la base
de cette relation
avec Dieu
qui nous permet
de manifester
cet amour
et de grandir
en santé
envers les autres
indépendamment
de leurs comportements
ou des difficultés
qu'on traverse
Ravel va dire
la foi
nous unit à Dieu
l'espérance
nous fait
anticiper
la gloire future
et l'amour
nous lie
les uns aux autres
dans les corps
du Christ
ces trois
sont inséparables
et ensemble
forment la somme
de notre vie chrétienne
Lloyd-Jones va dire
ces trois vertus
la foi
espérance
et l'amour
sont inséparables
la foi
nous unit à Christ
l'espérance
garde nos yeux
fixés
sur la gloire
du Christ à venir
et l'amour
est la preuve
d'un cœur
transformé
par les deux
donc c'est important
pour nous
de nous rappeler
comme on a déjà dit
que comme ces choses
nous viennent
surtout et d'abord
directement
de la part des dieux
elles sont
les trois
nécessaires au salut
mais pour ce qui concerne
la manière
dont on s'approprie
de cette foi
qui sauve
ou du Christ
ou de l'œuvre
du Christ
pour nous sauver
nous ne pouvons pas dire
que nous sommes sauvés
par l'amour
c'est pas l'amour
pour Dieu
qui nous a sauvés
nous sommes sauvés
par la foi
par contre
la foi qui sauve
n'est jamais
absent d'amour
et quelque part
c'est l'amour
de Dieu
qui nous a sauvés
lorsqu'on était
encore pécheurs
c'est lui
qui a eu cet amour
déterminé
à nous sauver
qui a envoyé son
c'est lui
qui l'aime le plus
pour mourir pour nous
et c'est son cordage
d'amour
qui nous a attirés
la révélation
de l'amour
de Dieu
suprême
se trouve
dans la présentation
du Christ
au perdu
et donc
faire confiance
à Christ
et se répentir
de ses péchés
passe par
l'expérience
d'avoir contemplé
la gloire
de Dieu
être attiré
par sa beauté
désirer
plus que
toute autre chose
dans sa vie
avoir la réconciliation
avec Dieu
accès à sa présence
il a vu Dieu
comme l'objet
suprême d'amour
mais en même temps
il voit qu'il est indigne
qu'il est coupable
qu'il ne mérite pas
qu'il ne peut accéder
et c'est à ces moments même
que Christ
est présenté par l'esprit
et donc
la répentance
est déjà marquée
par un amour
envers Dieu
et la foi
qui embrasse Christ
de manière très volontaire
est caractérisée
par l'amour révélé
envers l'amabilité
du Christ
qui nous sauve
donc c'est pas
l'amour abstrait
qui nous sauve
mais c'est une foi
toujours remplie d'amour
par contre
la transition importante
pour nous
théologique
à cet égard
c'est de savoir
que cet amour initial
qui nous a unis
à Dieu
et à Christ
va marquer
donc l'amour
est quelque part
la nature
ou l'essence
de cet évangile
qui nous sauve
mais l'amour
est aussi
les résultats
et l'évidence
de la foi
qui sauve
et donc
il faut que ça soit
toujours
profondément expérimental
et rempli d'affection
c'est lorsque
vous cherchez
à évaluer votre salut
et que vous avez
la capacité
de décrire
exactement
toute la logique
et tous les aspects
de justice
pourquoi
l'oeuvre du Christ
est parfaite
et parfaitement capable
de satisfaire
toutes les demandes
de la justice
des dieux
vous avez parcouru
un bon chemin
si vous avez
la confiance
qui sait que
Christ a fait
pourrait s'appliquer
dans vos vies
et ça serait
suffisant
pour vous sauver
c'est encore
une étape nécessaire
par contre
si vous n'avez
pas la perception
d'aimer
cet évangile
et d'aimer
ces sauveurs
si vous n'avez
jamais traversé
une expérience
d'amour pour Dieu
et pour Christ
on n'a pas dépassé
la capacité intellectuelle
des démons
qui connaissent
très bien
l'évangile
donc la foi
qui sauve
elle est profondément
expérimentale
et cet amour
qui est les fruits
de l'esprit
est un résultat
de cette relation
d'amour
avec Dieu
sans laquelle
nous ne pouvons pas
aimer
si les fruits
de l'esprit
est une évidence
si l'amour
de ceux
qui sont les seuls
qui peuvent être
identifiés
comme ceux
qui hériteront
les royaumes
des dieux
si les fruits
amour
est une évidence
c'est clair
que cet amour
a dû être
connu
de manière expérimentale
pour qu'il puisse
déborder
envers les autres
donc
les fruits
de l'esprit
pardon
l'amour
est
capital
elle est plus importante
entre toutes facettes
car même
lorsque
ces trois vertus
nous sont présentées
Paul
en première
contient 13
nous dit
maintenant
ces trois choses
demeurent
la foi
l'espérance
l'amour
mais
la plus grande
de ces choses
est l'amour
l'ordre
nous aide
à comprendre ça
la deuxième chose
qui nous aide
à comprendre
l'importance
capitale
de l'amour
c'est car l'amour
elle est seule
capable
et c'est celui
carrément
que la Bible nous présente
c'est lui
qui supporte
qui soutient
et donne du sens
à toutes les autres vertus
par exemple
si vous voulez
illustrer
comme j'ai fait
dans les dernières semaines
pour travailler un peu
avec les enfants
pour dessiner
et expliquer
les fruits de l'esprit
je pense que la clémentine
serait une bonne
illustration
donc
si on essaye
d'être très précis
on a l'impression
qu'on devrait avoir
9 parts
et la clémentine
nous donne 8
et ça nous aide
encore plus
car la réalité
c'est que l'amour
si vous voulez
pour illustrer bien
étant
la vertu
toute intégratrice
et toute inclusive
il va être
plutôt représenté
par les membranes
par les fibres
par les cloisons
vasculaires
je dirais même
par les goûts
ou les jus
qui vous trouverez
dans l'ensemble
de ces vertus
et donc
les fruits de l'esprit
et l'amour
pour certains théologiens
on devrait avoir
un point ici
ou en deux points
et l'amour
deux points
joie
patience
etc
expression
d'amour
manifestation
chaque vertu
une facette
ou expression
particulière
d'amour
la joie
trouve sa plénitude
dans l'amour
des dieux
et du prochain
la joie
quel était
le moment
le plus joyeux
de la vie
de tout chrétien
c'est lui
qui a trouvé
cette perle
cachée dans un champ
il va vendre
tout ce qu'il possède
pour l'acheter
débordant des joies
cette soif
que nous avons
cette demande d'amour
qu'est-ce qui nous remplit
des joies
quelle est la nature
des plaisirs
qu'on puisse expérimenter
dans la vie
on peut avoir
beaucoup de plaisir
par rapport aux choses
qu'il a créées
et qui satisfait
plusieurs demandes du corps
de l'intellect
même par la mathématique
de résoudre
quelques puzzles
dans les champs
de la sagesse
ou de la philosophie
nous pouvons passer
beaucoup de temps
toutes seules
et prendre plaisir
en plusieurs choses
mais les plaisirs
relationnels
d'amour
sont les plus capables
de nous remplir
des joies
mais pas
n'importe quel type
d'amour
car nous n'avons qu'il
des amours
imparfaits
entre nous
Dieu nous a créés
pour aimer
à son image
car il est amour
il est la seule
ou les seuls
objets capables
de satisfaire
la demande
la plus profonde
de l'homme humain
et donc cette joie
est un débordement
d'amour
envers Dieu
et d'un amour
reçu de la part
de Dieu
et qu'il va déborder
bien sûr
envers les prochains
la paix
repose
sur l'amour
qui réconcilie
tout
la paix
comme l'écrit
va développer
davantage
envers la pacification
ou la réconciliation
dans les béatitudes
heureux
ceux qui procurent
la paix
car ils seront
appelés
enfants des dieux
l'une des manifestations
de l'amour
des dieux
ou la manifestation
suprême
de l'amour
des dieux
envers nous
c'est la manière
dont il a promu
la réconciliation
à travers son fils
et donc la paix
repose
sur l'amour
car
elle est déterminée
à préserver
cette relation
qui devrait être
incassable
inséparable
la patience
est rendue
possible
par cet amour
qui supporte
tout
et qui se perd tout
et qui ne les pourrions
pas exercer
si Christ
n'avait pas exercé
envers nous
donc cette patience
est rendue possible
par l'amour
la bonté
définit
l'amabilité
de celui
qui reflète
la symétrie
de l'amabilité
des dieux
je vais vous expliquer
on va comprendre
que la bonté ici
n'est pas
la bienveillance
ou la bénignité
qui vient après
la bénignité
ou la bienveillance
c'est
faire les biens
envers les autres
la bonté
c'est plutôt
la question
de l'intégrité
est-ce qu'on est
en train de fonctionner
comme on est vrai
est-ce qu'on est bon
devant les yeux
des dieux
c'est cette préoccupation
avec l'intégrité
des choses
d'avoir la capacité
si vous voulez
de prendre
cette symétrie
de toutes ces vertus
et de nous présenter
à chaque fois
devant dieux
et les autres
avec cette bonté
des caractères
vous êtes avec moi ?
cette amabilité
de ces caractères
mais c'est impossible
si nous n'avons pas
les repères
de cette symétrie
parfaite
en Christ
de contempler Christ
et trouver
toutes ses facettes
en parfait équilibre
et donc la bonté
est ce qui nous devrions
être en tant
qu'image des dieux
en tant
qu'en reflet
des dieux
et c'est ce que nous
trouvons
quand on contemple
Dieu
dans sa beauté
dans son intégrité
c'est l'amabilité
des dieux
qui devrait être
communiquée
par cette amabilité
lorsqu'on voit
une personne
qui vit ses vertus
la bienveillance
c'est cette expression
tangible d'amour
et la foi
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
faire confiance
ou obéir
comme expression
de confiance
avec la certitude
que les choses
qui par la foi
en espère
s'accompliront
mais c'est aussi
la fidélité
qui ressort
de cette relation
des fois
d'union
avec Christ
et donc
cette fidélité
authentique
elle est motivée
par amour
et cette fidélité
n'est pas résumée
à une considération
d'amour
qui est tout simplement
réduit au sentiment
mais c'est
un amour
lié à la vérité
c'est un amour
lié à la justice
c'est d'être
fidèle
à long terme
et la seule chose
qui peut nous rendre
fidèle
à long terme
c'est l'amour
la douceur
est déterminée
à promouvoir
l'amour
par un traitement
amoureux
d'être constant
à manifester
notre amour
et chercher
le mieux
du prochain
malgré
ses réactions
ses inconstances
et de décider
d'agir
avec amour
manifester
l'amour
en reconnaissant
que c'est
de cette manière
que Dieu a révélé
son amour
pour moi
malgré
ma rébellion
et la maîtrise
de soi
empêche
que nous nous blessons
et que nous blessions
les autres
ceux qui ont des vrais
aimés
et la seule chose
qui peut nous donner
la capacité
de prendre soin
de nous
comme il faut
et des autres
c'est par amour
pour Dieu
et donc
l'essence
la base
la somme
les fibres
les goûts
du fruit de l'esprit
c'est d'être aimable
c'est d'être aimant
c'est l'amour
c'est les goûts
qui ressort
est-ce que c'est les goûts
de nos vies
l'amour chrétien
par toutes ses vertus
donc sans
cette essence
et sans la substance
qui est l'amour
aucune autre facette
mais authentique
nous avons lu
pendant les offrandes
première
quantien 13
qui nous rappelle
même si je parlerai
en langue
des hommes
ou des anges
si je n'ai pas
la charité
ou l'amour
je suis
comme un errant
qui ressonne
ou un cymbale
qui rétient
qui rétent
pardon
rétentit
et quand j'aurai
les dons
des prophéties
la science
de tous les mystères
et de toutes connaissances
quand j'aurai même
toute la foi
jusqu'à transporter
les montagnes
si je n'ai pas
la charité
ou l'amour
je ne suis rien
et quand je distribuerai
tous mes biens
pour la nourriture
des pauvres
quand je livrerai
même mon corps
pour être brûlé
si je n'ai pas
l'amour
cela ne me sert à rien
par plusieurs raisons
différentes
les êtres humains
peuvent être amenés
à dissimuler
ces vertus
qui ne peuvent pas
être authentiques
qui peuvent être
profondément corrompus
même
dans ses facettes
être plutôt
un indice
d'idolâtrie
si l'amour
n'est pas là
donc
s'il n'y a pas
cette intégrité
cette colle
qui unit
toutes ces vertus
qui a la substance
de toutes ces vertus
qui est en train
d'imprégner
toutes ces vertus
il n'y aura jamais
la manifestation
du vrai fruit
ni dans ses facettes
ni dans son ensemble
pour plus
que dans l'apparence
et dans l'externe
on ait l'impression
que cette personne
est joyeuse
pacifique
patiente
les goûts
sortira toujours
un peu amère
par exemple
la joie
peut être
le fruit
d'une dissimulation
dimanche
c'est le jour
de montrer
notre joie
mais comment
nous sommes en train
de manifester
cette joie
pendant
la continuité
de nos vies
les fruits
constants
de l'esprit
la joie
peut être
tout simplement
quelque chose
d'égoïste
je suis dans la joie
qui est lorsque
mes plaisirs
ou mes demandes
personnelles
sont respectées
ou satisfaites
la joie
peut être
tout simplement
charnelle
on peut
ne pas
avoir
la capacité
de réjouir
avec
l'amour
la promotion
de la vie
des autres
avec
les biens
des autres
la joie peut être
très charnelle
qui est centrée
sur les petits
plaisirs
de cette vie
au lieu de nous réjouir
dans le fait
qu'on est aimé
des dieux
et qui nous sommes appelés
à prendre plaisir
tout simplement
dans l'amour
qui ne dépend pas
des circonstances
la joie du chrétien
devrait être
au-dessus
des circonstances
mais elle est
très circonstancielle
s'il n'y a pas
l'amour
la paix
peut aussi
être dissimulée
elle peut être
superficielle
et circonstancielle
les assauts
d'anxiété
complètement
exposée
aux variations
d'humeur
provoquées
par la difficulté
qui certains
me présentent
ou les difficultés
qui surviennent
sur ma vie
Jésus a guéri
les problèmes
de l'anxiété
en nous rappelant
de l'amour paternel
des dieux
envers son peuple
commandement
ne soyez pas
inquiet
est-ce que la paix
dans ma vie
est trouvée
ancrée
dans l'amour
des dieux
est-ce que la paix
que je représente
lorsque j'arrive
dans un endroit
représente
l'amour
des dieux
qui m'a réconcilié
avec lui
et qui me donne
la paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
ou est-ce que la paix
va dépendre
tout simplement
des saisons favorables
ou des psychotropes
que je peux prendre
dans le jour
la patience
elle aussi
peut être dissimulée
confondue
parfois
avec la paresse
ou une espèce
de fatalisme
pragmatique
l'autre jour
j'ai entendu
un entretien
avec
une célébrité
et il expliquait
comment
il est passé
d'être une personne
très pessimiste
à une personne
très optimiste
et ses arguments
étaient
tout simplement
pragmatiques
il a dit
ça peut
ne pas m'aider
d'anticiper
beaucoup les mal
si j'arrive
au moment
où les choses
vont se passer
et que les choses
vont mal
au moins
je n'ai qu'à souffrir
à ces moments-là
et si j'anticipe
le mieux
et que les choses
vont mal
je souffrir
à ces moments-là
et en plus
j'ai vécu
plusieurs jours
mieux
donc il y a
de l'intelligence
derrière ça
sauf que
selon la Bible
notre patience
n'est pas basée
sur une incertitude
vis-à-vis au futur
mais c'est la certitude
de cet amour
inébranlable
des dieux
qui fait que
toutes les choses
coopèrent pour mon bien
la patience
souffre
endure
et persévère
non en se disant
dieu est tellement
souvérant
je n'ai besoin
de rien faire
mais
il est constant
dans la diligence
pour s'aimer
ce qu'il sait
qu'il doit faire
à chaque étape
car il est motivé
et il est imprégné
d'un amour
constant dans sa vie
Joseph
il ne savait pas
quel jour
ou s'il deviendrait
gouverneur d'Egypte
mais même s'il était
un frère d'une famille
qui les persécutait
un esclave
ou un prisonnier
il a tout fait
pour amour à Dieu
avec excellence
la bonté
elle manquera
son élément
le plus fondamental
et sera toujours
désintégrée
donc à nouveau
je vous rappelle
la bonté
c'est cette symétrie
cet équilibre
c'est la sagesse
de savoir
par exemple
quelle manifestation
d'amour
affichée
à quelles circonstances
donc
si je suis devant
une situation
où pour manifester
l'amour
je dois manifester
l'indignation
contre les péchés
confronter les personnes
cela n'est pas
de manquer
de patience
mais
en douceur
chercher
à promouvoir
les mieux
de ces personnes
donc la bonté
sans amour
elle sera
fragmentée
mécanique
car
on peut regarder
la vie de cette personne
elle peut s'éventer
car au travail
elle est bonne
elle respecte
toutes les règles
dans l'environnement
du travail
elle est diligente
pour développer
ses formations
par contre
dans sa vie privée
on ne voit pas
la même symétrie
les mêmes ailes
la bonté
elle peut être
quelque chose
chercher
avec un zèle
fanatique
je me rappelle
un jour
je suis allé
à la Sacré-Cœur
je faisais
des tours touristiques
j'avais un client
et j'ai profité
à chaque fois
pour évangéliser
pour partager l'évangile
je rentre
dans la Sacré-Cœur
j'explique un peu
quels étaient
les contextes catholiques
de l'époque
j'essaye de corriger
certaines choses
et bien sûr
que j'essaye de parler
très doucement
avec une voix faible
par contre
il y avait une personne
à l'église
dont son travail
c'était des
chuuut
tous ceux qui entraient
à l'église
les yeux
encolérés
avec un zèle
pour les silences
au sein de l'église
à cause
de l'ordre
ou la bonté
du déroulé
du culte
ou du déroulé
de l'ambiance
qui représente
cet aspect solennel
assez obscur
catholique
donc
elle a pu
crocher une case
pour maintenir
la bonté
de l'environnement
mais elle a raté
toutes les autres
la sensibilité
quel est l'objectif
dans cette situation
est-ce qu'il s'est
défait connaître
Christ et son amour
et donc
ces ailes
cet ordre
peut devenir fanatique
c'est ces ailes
contre lesquelles
Paul avait déjà parlé
quand il parlait
des œuvres de la chair
ou par exemple
les commandements du Christ
lorsqu'il dit
bénissez
ceux qui vous maudissent
aimez votre ennemi
priez pour ceux
qui vous persécutent
il y a un épisode aussi
c'est tragique
mais assez drôle
la personne
dans l'extérieur
de la surface
peut accomplir
apparemment
un commandement
et donc
c'est
c'est la belle mère
d'un pasteur
un ami à moi
et il raconte
cet épisode
où elle a été volée
à Rio
et lorsqu'elle a été volée
elle était en colère
mais elle s'est rappelée
du commandement du Christ
et il dit
qu'elle a fait comme ça
que Dieu vous bénisse
le cœur
plein des malédictions
mais en faisant les choses
dans la surface
si l'amour n'est pas là
si nous ne connaissons pas
l'amour du Christ
qui nous a aimés
parce qu'on était encore
ses ennemis
aucune de ses vertus
ne sera authentique
ne sera symétrique
les goûts
d'une action
qu'on pense être
en train de manifester
la bonté
sortira mère
la bénignité
peut être centré
sur soi
sur ses propres intérêts
mettre la lumière
envers moi-même
ma libéralité
elle peut être
circonstancielle
que lorsque je suis
dans la prospérité
elle peut être
en constante
si l'amour
n'est pas constant
la foi
cette fidélité
elle peut être
non authentique
basée sur les propres intérêts
basée sur les menaces
et récompenses
oscillantes
en constante
et la douceur
peut être confondue
parfois
avec un comportement
ou un tempérament
plus pacifique
un comportement lâche
une personne
qui veut éviter
à tout prix
les confrontations
mais qui ne garde pas
sa fidélité
lorsque la situation exige
la douceur
peut
s'est camuflé
par une voix
très douce
ou les baisers
d'un serpent
comme celui
du baiser
des Judas
envers Christ
ou des attaques
constantes
subtiles
et amères
qu'avec une doigre
une voix
très douce
parfois
vélutée
et comme ces gouttes
qui n'arrêtent
de tomber
et qui cumulent
en faisant du mal
mieux veut
une réprimande
ouverte
qu'une amitié cachée
les blessures
d'un ami
prouvent sa fidélité
mais les baisers
d'un ennemi
sont trompeurs
et donc la vraie douceur
elle est toujours
dans la direction
du vrai amour
et la maîtrise de soi
elle sera désintégrée
mécanique
basée sur des motivations
égoïstes
ou idolâtres
comme
la maîtrise de soi
des pharisiens
l'intégration
la symétrie
les proportions
toutes les vertus
ensemble
manifestées
dans les circonstances
nécessaires
ce sont des vertus
que nous ne pouvons
qu'y manifester
si nous sommes
profondément
et intimement
et constamment
unis à Christ
disons les pages
du Nouveau Testament
observons la vie du Christ
et c'est impossible
de prendre
un comportement
dans une situation
spécifique
et universalisée
!
car devant
chaque circonstance
on était surpris
par une réaction
particulière du Christ
et pour plus
que ça pourrait
surprendre
un hypocrite
guérir en sabbat
manger en sabbat
coup de fouet
dans les temples
part dans l'heure
lorsqu'il est en train
de mourir à la croix
comment trouver
cette symétrie
cet équilibre
comment savoir
que nous ne pouvons pas
agir de manière
mécanique
tous les temps
embrasser
toutes les sortes
de
formats
une moule
uniformalisée
toutes les situations
avoir des règles
et des règles extra
pour chaque situation
spécifique
de la vie
l'égalisme
ça va dépendre
complètement
de cet amour
expérimental
dans mon intimité
constante
avec le Christ
qui se manifeste
à travers ma vie
et donc
c'est important
car il est
les premiers
dans la liste
c'est important
aussi
car il supporte
soutient
et donne
doucement
à toutes les autres
vertus
c'est aussi
troisième point
important
car il est
le victorieux
souverain
l'amour
contre
les deux extrêmes
de la religion
le légalisme
et la carnalité
une relation
envers Dieu
qui cherche
à les plaire
par ses propres efforts
et qui se sent
toujours menacé
par
la menace
des punitions
ou perte du salut
et motivé
par les récompenses
qu'on peut recevoir
d'un côté
l'égalisme
et de l'autre côté
l'antinomisme
ou cette idée
qu'au nom de la grâce
des dieux
qui nous a sauvés
complètement
basée sur
Christ seulement
pardon absolu
et complet
assurance
non perte du salut
les personnes vont se dire
si tout est assuré
je peux me livrer
au péché
aucun
de ces deux extrêmes
ne peut représenter
la vraie foi
et la vraie foi
enracinée
dans l'amour
de Dieu
de son esprit
elle est vécue
dans l'atmosphère
de l'amour
on revient
verset 13
vous avez été
appelé
à la liberté
seulement
ne faites pas
de cette liberté
un prétexte
pour vivre
selon la chair
mais rendez-vous
impératif
par l'amour
serviteurs
les uns des autres
car toute la loi
est accomplie
dans une seule parole
celle-ci
tu aimeras ton prochain
comme toi-même
la loi
!
envers laquelle
les légalistes
se comportaient
comme si c'était
quai de la terreur
était résumée
par l'amour
et l'amour
est l'accomplissement
de la loi
si mon rapport
en tant que chrétien
vers la loi
de l'éternel
n'est pas celui
du psaumiste
comme j'aime ta loi
tous les commandements
ancien testament
nouveau testament
tout ce qu'on peut
trouver en tant
que commandement
qu'est-ce que Dieu
exige de moi
qui ne représente pas
ses soins
pour manifester
son amour
envers nous
et me protéger
de moi-même
ou la manifestation
de l'extension
de son amour
envers l'autrui
qui peut mettre
en question
un seul commandement
de Dieu
comme si il n'était pas
la manifestation
d'amour
et de l'autre côté
si quelqu'un
a été
véritablement
pardonné
si quelqu'un
a véritablement
expérimenté
un pardon
où il s'est voyé
complètement condamné
à l'enfer
c'est impossible
que les rapports
du chrétien
envers son père céleste
n'aient pas
pour amour
les fondements
de son désir
d'obéir
donc de dire
car Dieu est très bon
je vais me plonger
dans les péchés
c'est l'une des plus
grandes évidences
des non-conversions
comme les puritains
disaient
n'est considéré
pas
être sauvé
sans que l'évidence
du salut
soit présente
la sanctification
l'amour
pour Dieu
et donc
c'est intéressant
car ici
dans ces passages
non seulement
l'amour
accomplit
pleinement
la loi
mais
il débarrasse
ces inclinations
qu'on considère
plus charnelles
car toutes ces choses
sont œuvres de la chair
revenons verset 19
les œuvres de la chair
elles se portent
vers la direction
du légalisme
elles se portent
vers la direction
du libertinage
et voilà pourquoi
Paul présente
les fous de l'esprit
comme les conquérants
victorieux
contre l'égalisme
et contre le libertinage
or les œuvres de la chair
sont manifestes
impudicité
impureté
dissolution
idolâtrie
magie
et là on pense
ce sont vraiment
les païens
qui n'ont jamais eu
un arrière-plan
religieux
biblique
mais ensuite
il va parler
de cette usurpation
du roi des dieux
de la part
des pharisiens
les inimités
les querelles
les jalousies
les animalités
les disputes
les divisions
les sectes
l'envie
et je vous rappelle
ces jalousies
liées à ces ailes
corrompues
la manière
de chercher
à exploiter
la foi des personnes
par des outils religieux
et ensuite
en reviant
à ce qui peut être
considéré
comme plus charnel
l'ivronnerie
les excès de table
et les choses semblables
contrairement à ça
Paul va présenter
au verset 22
mais les fruits
de l'esprit
est l'amour
et au verset 23
il va dire
la loi
n'est pas contre ces choses
vous comprenez ?
contre le légalisme
accomplir la loi
c'est l'amour
et couplé
au fruit
de l'esprit
contrairement
à toute manifestation
charnel
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
et c'est 18
il dit
si vous êtes conduits
par l'esprit
vous n'êtes
point sous la loi
et au chapitre 2
de verset
pardon
au verset 2
de chapitre 6
il dit
portez les fardeaux
les uns des autres
et vous accomplirez
la loi du Christ
rendez-vous
par la charité
serviteur
les uns des autres
qu'est-ce qu'il peut
nous enseigner ici
c'est que si quelqu'un
est né de nouveau
il est né de l'amour
il est né pour aimer
il est imprégné
de l'amour du Christ
et il va déborder
en amour
envers les autres
la base
c'est que la loi du Christ
elle peut être considérée
comme quelque part
indépendante
de la loi
nous savons très bien
que Dieu
de manière didatique
nous a communiqué
tout ce qu'on devrait
accomplir par la loi
afin qu'on soit sûr
que Christ a tout accompli
en obéissant parfaitement
à la loi
sauf que Christ
étant la parole
faite chère
il est
l'incarnation
de Dieu
il est l'incarnation
de la substance
de la loi
la vraie substance
l'amour
par l'observation
du Christ
et par les désirs
d'imiter Christ
c'est impossible
de ne pas accomplir
la loi
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc la loi du Christ
c'est
en cherchant
à me plonger
dans l'amour
de Dieu
révélé en Christ
en cherchant
de reproduire
l'amour du Christ
débordant
à travers ma vie
envers les autres
je suis naturellement
en train d'accomplir
la loi
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc la loi
pour nous les chrétiens
elle est plus au-dessus
de nous pour nous condamner
car nous sommes un Christ
et il a tout accompli
mais nous pouvons
utiliser de la loi
pour marcher
en Christ
sur la loi
avec Christ
Jean 14
verset 20
encore
en ce jour-là
Jésus l'a dit
vous connaîtrez
que je suis en mon Père
et que vous êtes en moi
et que je suis en vous
celui qui a mes commandements
et qui les garde
c'est celui qui m'aime
et celui qui m'aime
sera aimé de mon Père
je l'aimerai
et je me ferai connaître
à lui
qu'est-ce qu'on doit
tirer d'ici
c'est cette
autorité
parentale
qui fait
que la seule
obéissance
qui puisse compter
devant Dieu
soit l'obéissance
motivée par amour
et imprégnée
d'amour
si
nous pouvons
nous pouvons faire
toutes les sortes
d'obéissance religieuse
si elle n'est pas
motivée par l'amour
et si
elle n'est pas
imprégnée d'amour
elle ne vaut
rien
devant les visages
des dieux
rien
comment nous devons
éduquer
nos enfants
il y a eu
un ministère
dans la période
du ministère
de Lloyd-Jones
en Angleterre
en Londres
il y avait un ministère
qui parcourait
tous les pays
et
ces ministères
de l'Eutré
c'était le ministère
d'une femme
d'une mère
qui avait
si je ne me trompe
quatre enfants
et dans
toutes les attentes
comportamentales
visibles
de l'extérieur
il semblait
que c'était
la famille parfaite
ils avaient
même la capacité
enfants
encore
de rester assis
en silence
pendant toute la durée
d'un culte
et plusieurs personnes
regardaient
cette situation
et faisaient
énormément
de loge
Lloyd-Jones
avec son expérience
sa sagesse
avec sa perception
de l'histoire
d'Israël
l'Ancien Testament
il disait
au plus proche
de lui
on ne va pas inviter
on va juste
observer
on va attendre
c'est terrible
mais malheureusement
lorsque ces enfants
arrivent à l'adolescence
à la jeunesse
ils se perdent tous
préoccupation
de Lloyd-Jones
lorsqu'on va
en déterronome
l'encouragement
à enseigner
nos enfants
les lever
les coucher
les longs
du chemin
interprétation
pour Lloyd-Jones
c'est contempler
comment Israël
vivait sa foi
c'était
en toute occasion
qu'elle soit
formelle
cadrée
ou organique
la conception
d'une parentalité
qui doit coupler
la représentation
de l'amour
du père
qui doit être
la motivation
suprême
pour l'obéissance
des enfants
en respectant
les caractéristiques
de chaque âge
on n'est pas
attendant
d'un enfant
un comportement
mécanique
lorsqu'il les
disciple
voulait éviter
que les enfants
fassent beaucoup
de bruit
qui gênent
les enseignements
du Christ
laissez
venir à moi
les petits
il les porte
dans les bras
et il enseigne
avec un enfant
sur ses bras
pour Lloyd-Jones
lui qui est
dans sa biographie
on va
regarder
ces vidéos
des luttes
ces luttes
un peu drôles
un peu
hollywoodiennes
là
avec ces petits
enfants
sur
sur ses bras
qui rigolaient
pour lui
c'est surtout
l'amour
pour Dieu
qui doit
transparaître
c'est saisir
chaque occasion
où l'intérêt
de l'enfant
est réel
nous en tant que parents
on doit
apprendre
à communiquer
une autorité
respectable
qui convendent
nos enfants
que notre autorité
se porte vers
leur bien
respecte
leurs limites
n'est pas
provoquer
la colère
de nos enfants
donc
pour reconnaître
mon autorité
et pour vouloir
respecter mon autorité
mon enfant
doit savoir
que moi en tant que père
moi en tant que mère
je veux son mieux
et en même temps
ma relation
d'amour
mes manifestations
de joie
de paix
vous êtes avec moi
des douceurs
des patience
envers mes enfants
!
doit promouvoir
la substance
d'amour
qui va conduire
mes enfants
à vouloir
m'obéir
pour me plaire
et moi
je suis
qui est inutile
pour enseigner
mes enfants
que c'est comme ça
que j'ai vu
ma vie envers Dieu
j'ai appris
à reconnaître
son autorité
et même
parfois
ma chère
ne veut pas
je vais obéir
je vais servir
car je suis convaincu
que ces commandements
ne sont pas pénibles
c'est pour mon bien
mais je suis convaincu
de cet amour
car un jour
j'ai expérimenté
son amour
j'ai découvert
des manifestations
de sa générosité
envers moi
des plaisirs
qui l'ont entouré
ma vie
dans les choses
les plus simples
en interagissant
avec nature
en réjouissant
de chaque étape
de ma vie
et qui m'a donné
envie
de volontairement
vivre une vie
plus belle
et plus obéissante
afin de plaire
les cœurs de Père
j'ai une riture
c'est ce que Jésus
dit aux disciples
c'est de faire
la volonté
de mon Père
qui est au ciel
nous devons travailler
pour que nos enfants
puissent dire
la même chose
nous aider
nous servir
nous aimer
de manière spontanée
nous respecter
bien sûr
convaincus
que nos lois
sont pour leur bien
c'est ça
la didatique
des dieux
c'est de nous convaincre
que nous devons
avoir l'amour
de l'esprit
pour être capable
de manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
nous ne pourrons pas
envisager une vie
très belle
et symétrique
si cette vertu
capitale
n'est pas présente
sans l'amour
impossible
de manifester
les fruits
de manière symétrique
authentique
sans l'amour
impossible
de ne pas développer
une mentalité légaliste
envers la foi
sans l'amour
impossible
de faire face
aux passions
charnelles
de la chair
sans l'amour
aucune facette
n'a aucune chance
contre l'illégalisme
ou la carnalité
sans l'amour
nous pouvons faire
des séries
d'études bibliques
contre
l'immoralité
sexuelle
la pornographie
mais la stratégie
des dieux
n'est pas citant
de nous concentrer
à ne pas dévelir
un diable
mais c'est de nous plonger
dans l'amour du Christ
et déborder
de l'amour du Christ
Thomas Chau
il disait
il parlait
de la puissance
expulsive
d'un envers l'amour
de nous concentrer
dans la contemplation
de l'amour
des dieux
révélé en Christ
pour chasser
de nos cœurs
tout sentiment
idolâtre
c'est l'attirance
de l'amour
des dieux
qui nous conduit
à vivre
une vie d'amour
alors lorsqu'on sera
défié
à aimer
contre l'amabilité
des personnes
ou contre
les circonstances
difficiles
qu'on traverse
nous n'allons
qu'avoir la capacité
d'aimer
comme il faut
si nous sommes
imprégnés
de l'amour des dieux
d'aimer l'autre
c'est aimer
pour l'amour
à Dieu
c'est difficile
d'aimer les prochains
oui
mais Dieu l'aime
je dois l'aimer
ok
mais je dois aimer aussi
pour une question
de justice
si Dieu
m'a aimé
malgré moi
je dois
l'amour
comme dit l'apôtre Paul
n'élever
à personne
aucune chose
à part l'amour
l'évangile
mais Dieu
est intéressé
avec
un exercice
plus élevé
que ça
certains disent
aimer les prochains
comme soi-même
c'est réglé en nous
car on ne s'aime pas
trop tous les jours
mais on cherche
toujours notre mieux
ok
mais si
si cet amour
n'est pas expérimental
on n'est pas encore
arrivé
au commandement
biblique
c'est pas
pour dire
l'amour est aussi action
il est aussi action
mais il n'est pas
qu'action
il n'est pas action
vide
d'affection
et la seule manière
d'aimer l'autre
c'est d'aimer l'autre
pour les mêmes raisons
que Dieu les aime
avec les potentiels
que tout être humain a
malgré sa perdition actuelle
douceur envers eux
car nous savons
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
esclaves du péché
ils sont esclaves
de Satan
du monde
je serai doux
envers eux
je les aimerai
car Dieu m'a aimé
en connaissant mon potentiel
pour me restaurer
pour me faire image
des dieux à nouveau
mais nous devons
et ça c'est
les fondements suprêmes
nous ne pouvons qu'aimer
comme il faut
et manifester cet amour
si nous sommes
enracinés
et imprégnés
de l'amour du Christ
greffés à Christ
avec moi
pour conclure
greffés à Christ
ce n'est plus moi
qui vis
c'est Christ
qui vit en moi
c'est pas que Christ
va vivre sa vie
à travers moi
indépendamment de moi
non
il va vivre
vivre en moi
et à travers moi
j'ai perdu mon identité
en Christ
je me suis retrouvé
mon identité
a une continuité
mais prédominant
c'est le fait
que maintenant
je suis en branche
greffée à Christ
sa vie coule à travers moi
les sentiments
que Christ a
envers les perdus
autour de moi
c'est les sentiments
que moi aussi
j'expérimente
au sein de mon cœur
comment peut-je
expérimenter cet amour
et communiquer cet amour
étant
enraciné
et fondé
sur l'amour de Christ
et